مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من التوترات
المتصاعده في اسرائيل طبعا بسبب خطه رئيس
الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لتغيير النظام
القضائي رغم ان التقارير الاسرائيليه تشير
الى ان نتنياهو ابلغ قاده الائتلاف الحاكم
عزمه وتعليق التعديلات القضائيه والتي ادت
الاحتجاجات ادت الى اضرابات وهي تعتبر
الاكبر ضد الحكومه من اجل تراجعها الا ان
قاده المعارضه يبدو انهم دخلوا في مرحله
اللاعوده حيث قرروا عدم العدول عن
احتجاجاتهم الا بعد الغاء التعديلات لا
بعد تجميدها طبعا خوفا من تحول التظاهرات
لمواجهات بين المؤيدين والمعارضين
للتعديلات القضائيه المثيره للجدل نتنياهو
دعا المتظاهرين للامتناع عن العنف وفي
تغريده على حسابه عبر تويتر شدد على ضروره
اي تصرف المتظاهرون من اليمين واليسار
بمسؤوليه
قبل ذلك دفع نتنياهو عن خطته لتغيير
النظام القضائي قال ان حكومته تواجه حمله
دعائيه سلبيه مشيرا الى ان المحتجين
وطنيين لكنهم لا يفهمون الاصلاح الذي يدعو
اليه ودفتره قناه 12 الاسرائيليه ان
مقربين من نتنياهو نصحوه بالتعجيل بخطابه
الذي تم تاجيله اكثر من مره لمحاوله تهدئه
غضب الشارع حيث من المقرر ان يعلن عزمه
تعليق التعديلات
ورغم دعوات نتنياهو للتهدئه وايضا لتجنب
العنف الا ان وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اتمار بنك في ردعها انصاره الى
تنظيم مظاهرات مضاده وذلك في القدس فيما
وصل عدد المتظاهرين بمحيط الكنيست الى 80
الفا بحسب ما اوردت الشرطه الاسرائيليه في
غضون ذلك هدد ناشطون من اقصى اليمين
باعمال عنف ردا على الاحتجاجات بينما دفعت
شرطه القدس بمئات من قواتها خوفا من
اشتباكات بين مؤيدين ومعارضين للتعديلات
القضائيه